[Musique]
salut les amis bienvenue dans thimphou
your life
vous avez un problème nous trouverons la
solution voici régis régis a du mal à
trouver un job n'est fait mais pas assez
sûr de lui et a du mal à s'exprimer en
public
objectif faire de régis le pro des
entretiens d'embauché c'est parti
[Musique]
régis bienvenue dans notre qg c'est ici
que la magie va opérer en un coup d'oeil
on se rend vite compte que tu n'es pas
prêt à passer des entretiens mais c'est
tout ce qu'il faut pour passer un
entretien
je dirais avant toute chose un train cv
démontrant toutes les capacités négatif
ce qu'il te faut c'est ce petit truc en
plus c'est jeff à s'occuper ne te le
montrer let's go c'est là bas
regarde mon gars est-ce que ça tes
pattes
ouais ici tout un tas d'éléments qui te
permettront de décrocher un job mais
seul l'un d'entre eux fera de toi un as
des entretiens f2 pas toi mon gars non
non non non non
alors tu vas dit le sentir à l'instinct
ce truc as tu me fais une blague là
oui le van haaster focus
ouah
[Musique]
moi
ah ah
ce que tu sens prêt à face à l'entretien
voilà attention les recruteurs ils
arrivent sur le marché
c'est par lou bassi vijay n'est pas
encore suffisant pour garantir de la
réussite un entretien dustin va
s'occuper d'améliorer ça ok en apparence
c'est bon maintenant qu'il faut que tu
es plus d'assurance quand tu parle en
public ça fait un peu beaucoup de
concurrence ne le confirme maintenant
comment tu pense qu'on peut y parvenir
on travaille on mon allocution de façon
c'est pas du tout en insultant
non mr hockey régis ta mère elle est
tellement grosse qu'elle est incapable
d'aplanir
[Musique]
milk et lola mais ça s'est désolé reçues
sur le surtout te laisse pas faire et 6
à les toiles à quel âge ta mère atos pas
répondre à la koala 400 400 ans ou quoi
c'est pas mal ça à régis pas toi ta mère
elle est tellement feignasses qu'elle a
une télécommande pour sa télécommande
pourrait pas toi ta mère elle est
tellement conne que tant elle appelle
quelqu'un et que le correspondant en
ligne n'entend pas elle dit allô allô
allô
[Musique]
je veux d'édifices jeunes ont changé
d'opérateur si je pense que régis a
besoin d'un peu d'encouragement râler
tamer cette grosse [ __ ] si c'est pas
synonyme de confiance en soi
[Applaudissements]
ok les amis la mission de la team full
s'arrête ici
régis a maintenant tout ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir passer son entretien à der
sypt vo mise grâce à vous il ya aucune
chance que j'échoue à les défenses to
make raid go et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour aider
solange qui a du mal à oublier son petit
copain du nom de karl avec un aussi naze
moi aussi j'aurais certainement du mal à
oublier
[Rires]
égard par rapport aux trucs de chaume de
l'emploi la v mentir